notte serena il chiaro di luna illumina
i pendii rocciosi dell'arizona
un uomo si avventura fuori dalla grotta
dove aveva cercato riparo per sfuggire
agli indiani apache e improvvisamente
un'attrazione inspiegabile lo spinge a
danzare uno sguardo alla volta stellata
e ad allungare le braccia in direzione
del pianeta marte dove viene
istantaneamente proiettato con questa
scena nel 1912 edgar rice burroughs
inaugura all'ormai leggendario ciclo di
barsoom e le eroiche battaglie di john
carter per portare la pace su marte e
conquistare la principessa dejah thoris
il richiamo di marte è rimasto immutato
sin da allora per il trasporto invece le
cose si sono rivelate un po più
complicate di così dopo la missione
apollo marte si candidava essere il
successivo grande passo per l'umanità
a dire il vero il pianeta più vicino
sarebbe venere ma nonostante il nome
venere richiami bellezza e amore e marte
sia invece è associato a guerra e
violenza tra i due il più tranquillo e
ragionevole sembra essere proprio marte
non che sia un oasi le temperature medie
si aggirano attorno ai 60 gradi sotto
zero
la pressione atmosferica è quella che
troveremo al 35 km di quota e
stagionalmente si sviluppano tempeste di
polvere che durano anche mesi ma
rispetto ai 450 gradi di venere alle sue
92 atmosfere di pressione e agli
occasionali acquazzoni di acido
solforico diciamo che tutto sommato su
marte si sta anche benino di progetti
per mandare l'uomo su marte ne sono
stati fatti sin da quando sappiamo
lanciare roba nello spazio se non prima
werner von braun l'ingegnere dietro a
razzo saturn five che portò l'uomo sulla
luna
già nel secondo dopoguerra aveva
elaborato i primi studi tecnici
dettagliati per una missione umana sul
pianeta rosso
per inciso il il primo progetto
prevedeva la costruzione di una flotta
di astronavi da una stazione spaziale
orbitante con una richiesta di appena un
migliaio di lanci da terra da allora
sono state proposte circa una sessantina
dimissioni per marte sia da enti
pubblici sia da privati ma nessuna di
esse ha superato gli studi preliminari
in questo modo marte rischia di
diventare un frustrante simbolo dei
nostri limiti
con un occhio rossastro che ci scruta
continuamente ci rimprovera se non
riuscite a raggiungere me che sono qua
dietro dove altro volete andare nel
cosmo e il timore di non farcela di
restare confinati entro questa frontiera
causando una certa frenesia tra gli
appassionati che pur di vedere l'uomo su
marte il prima possibile sono disposti a
dar credito a qualunque idea di missione
anche di slh ma perché non ce l'abbiamo
ancora fatta di certo un viaggio per
marte è una bestia un po diversa
rispetto a un viaggio sulla luna se non
altro perché per arrivarci non ci
vogliono giorni ma mesi ed esistono
tutta una serie di vincoli di
limitazioni di b di rischi che non
sappiamo ancora in grado di gestire per
certe cose sapremmo come fare ma mancano
i soldi
una missione così lunga e complessa
richiederebbe un piano di grandi
investimenti a lungo termine
una prospettiva che i decisori politici
non sono tanto diciamo non so non
adottano tanto facilmente soprattutto in
tempi di crisi economica
in altri casi conosciamo il problema ma
non abbiamo ancora trovato una soluzione
in altri casi ancora non conosciamo
nemmeno a fondo il problema
in sostanza comunque il limite numero 1
siamo noi siamo già riusciti a mandare
oggetti su marte ma gran parte del costo
del rischio associati a una missione con
equipaggio gravitano proprio attorno
alla presenza di questi bipedi senzienti
che vanno nutriti protetti tenuti al
caldo e monitorati costantemente
affinché nel lungo tragitto
interplanetario e poi nel periodo di
permanenza su marte
non finiscono per cedere fisicamente
psicologicamente o entrambi per esempio
non è facile come fa sembrare una
fantascienza simulare la gravità
marziana facendo ruotare un'astronave su
se stessa e sfruttando così la forza
centrifuga e nei lunghi mesi di gravità
ridotta o assente il nostro corpo può
sviluppare fragilità ossea debolezza
muscolare scompensi cardiocircolatori
squilibri chimici nel sangue e via
discorrendo
fuori dalla protezione dell'atmosfera
gli astronauti saranno poi esposti a
delle radiazioni cosmiche extra e che
nel caso di un'eruzione solare possono
raggiungere i livelli anche mortali sarà
dunque necessario progettare un adeguata
schermatura che però non vada ad
aggiungere troppo peso all'astronave non
dimentichiamoci infatti che con le
attuali tecnologie di propulsione ogni
kg di carico aggiuntivo richiede
grossomodo 9 kg extra di propellente
solo per sollevarsi da terra e comporta
una spesa di migliaia di dollari
allo stesso modo ogni cosa è
contingentata nutrimento strumenti
farmaci e dispositivi medici pezzi di
ricambio per gli inevitabili guasti che
si verificheranno in tutto quel periodo
e per lo stesso motivo saranno
indispensabili dei sistemi di supporto
d'italia a circuito chiuso che siano in
grado di riciclare al cento per cento
gli scarti per produrre cibo ossigeno e
acqua sistemi che però non esistono
ancora
quanto poi all'arrivo vero e proprio su
marte basti sapere che al controllo
missione della nasa le fasi di ingresso
in atmosfera discesa e atterraggio sul
pianeta sono note con il nomignolo di
sette minuti di terrore perché
tantissime cose possono andare storte un
angolo di ingresso troppo troppo poco
inclinato una telemetria sbagliata un
errore di conversione di unità di misura
è successo e pouf miliardi di dollari in
fumo e rottami finora la cosa più
pesante mai giunta su marte è stato
curiosity una tonnellata scarsa di over
una astronave con equipaggio
supererà ampiamente questo limite e
dovrà atterrare su un terreno
sconosciuto potenzialmente accidentato
tra turbini di polvere e in completa
autonomia perché qualunque risposta
dalla terra a causa della distanza
arriverà almeno con dieci minuti diretta
di ritardo anche supponendo di avere le
soluzioni già pronte sulla carta non
disponiamo del budget dei tempi d'oro
dell'esplorazione spaziale che comunque
non sarebbe sufficiente quindi la
promessa reiterata di portare l'uomo su
marte entro 15 anni e destinata a
rimanere tale per qualche decennio
ancora
eppure per noi marte non è più solo un
pianeta ma è già un mondo perché ci
siamo già stati tante volte abbiamo
creduto di vedere enormi canali
planetari costruiti per convogliare
l'acqua di scioglimento dei poli sui
terreni di un mondo morente abbiamo
conosciuto varie utopie tra cui quella
sovietica di alexander bogdanov in
stella rossa in cui marte ospita una
società di tipo collettivista socialista
abbiamo spazzato via la civiltà marziana
la sua antica cultura e le sue città di
cristallo nelle cronache marziane di ray
bradbury fino a poi in tempo più recenti
quando abbiamo parteciparte giato per la
ribellione contro i governatori locali
capitanata da douglas quaid in atto di
forza insomma l'immaginazione di tanti
autori ci ha portati su marte superando
gli attuali limiti fisici e tecnologici
allo stesso tempo però ha portato alla
luce altri limiti di tipo diverso la
parte più complessa potrebbe rivelarsi
infatti non tanto l'arrivo sul pianeta
alieno ma convivere e confrontarsi con
l'alieno una volta l'alieno erano gli
omini verdi o simili ma negli anni 60 le
immagini delle sonde orbitanti e dei
lander hanno distrutto definitivamente
ogni speranza di trovare società
indigene sviluppate quindi il problema
si è spostato dallo scontro con delle
popolazioni locali
preesistenti e potenzialmente ostili
allo scontro con un ambiente
preesistente sicuramente ostile uno
scontro che va in due direzioni
il pianeta in sé ostile
era già un archetipo del nuovo realismo
fantascientifico negli anni 50 quando
queste due autorità arthur clarke e
isaac asimov
in questi due romanzi le sabbie di marte
e maledetti marziani pubblicati entrambi
nel 52 mettevano in discussione il mito
dell'utopia marziana per presentarci
invece un pianeta spoglio difficile dove
i coloni umani lavoravano senza sosta
per renderlo abitabile spesso in
condizioni proibitive
mentre la terra matura un'ostilità
crescente nei confronti di insediamenti
che sono molto costosi e poco redditizi
negli anni 60 invece è l'occhio l'occhio
psichedelico di philip dick a
raccontarci in questo marte allucinato e
squallido dove speculatori senza
scrupoli attirano manodopera terrestre
con visioni fallaci di nuova vita per
poi intrappolarli in questo non luogo
dove niente funziona il futuro non
esiste una delle immagini più
pessimistiche di questa lotta tra uomo e
marte viene da un illustratore
cecoslovacco luce e shaq che scrisse nel
1970 il romanzo la terra è vicina qui il
pianeta è un posto insidioso e
continuamente battuto dalle tempeste di
vento e i giorni si trascinano tra
continui incidenti conflitti personali e
enorme difficoltà tecniche di ogni tipo
che via via corrodono lo spirito e la
volontà dell'equipaggio una versione
contemporanea molto diversa di questa
lotta è quella di andy wer l'autore
dell'uomo di marte il romanzo da cui poi
è stato tratto il film di ridley scott e
del 2015
questa è una storia che reinterpreta
ancora una volta il tema della frontiera
in cui il protagonista ha creduto morto
nel corso di una missione su marte e lì
abbandonato deve dar fondo a tutte le
sue risorse e le conoscenze scientifiche
il suo ingegno per cavarsela
sopravvivere e tornare sulla terra
qui il tono ottimista l'impegno
collaborativo e l'accento sulla scienza
testimoniano come dagli anni 70 in poi
l'attrattiva di marte sia stata in
qualche modo rivitalizzata dalle
missioni avvenute da quegli anni e dai
panorami straordinari che ci hanno
restituito marte infatti ospita le
montagne più alte e i canyon più
profondi del sistema solare
vi sono delle dune gigantesche modellate
dal vento ci sono questi arabeschi
polari sono questi cieli rosa e antichi
delta fluviali e via discorrendo
pazienza se non c'è vita torna in auge
la mitologia marziana del pianeta
vergine un luogo sublime nel quale è
possibile costruire tutto da zero e
quando ci sarà arrivato per sentire
marte come il nuovo mondo la sua nuova
casa
l'uomo non si accontenterà di rimanere
confinato entro cupole e spazi
pressurizzati in moduli abitativi che
diventeranno più alienanti del pianeta
stesso
nell'impaccio delle tute spaziali vorrà
toccare con mano il mondo respirarlo
sentirlo
e allora che fare i promotori del sogno
marziano non hanno dubbi bisogna
terraformare bisogna rendere la
superficie del pianeta abitabile per
l'uomo quindi sostanzialmente aumentare
temperatura pressione atmosferica e
concentrazione di ossigeno e magari
anche creare un gigantesco scudo
magnetico artificiale come protezione
contro il vento solare
si tratta di un piano un po chimerico
che richiederebbe qualche migliaio di
anni se va bene per essere realizzato
però gode dell'appoggio degli entusiasti
di marte che arrivano a vedere nella
terra formazione una sorta di atto
demiurgico con il quale infondere la
vita in un pianeta morto
ecco da di farsi prendere la mano e
proporre si nucleari siamo marte per
liberare gas serra dai poli è un attimo
alcuni ricercatori propongono anche di
introdurre attivamente un cocktail di
microbi utili all'uomo che servirebbero
alterare la composizione dell'aria a
rendere il terreno coltivabile e via
discorrendo
d'altro canto è lecito domandarsi se
queste iniziative non denotino una
visione di marte un po troppo
antropocentrica l'attuale politica della
nasa richiede di preservare gli ami te
extraterrestri nel loro stato naturale
ma è inevitabile che nel momento in cui
si insedia in un nuovo ambiente
l'uomo lo modifichi profondamente non
siamo nemmeno sicuri al cento per cento
che non ci sia vita su marte infatti
l'anno prossimo è previsto il lancio di
due rover rosalind franklin dell'agenzia
spaziale europea e marzo entità menti
dalla nasa che con mezzi diversi hanno
lo scopo specifico di cercare tracce
biologiche negli strati della crosta
marziana eventuali interventi invasivi
di terraformazione finirebbero
sicuramente per alterare eco sistemi
preesistenti e andrebbero a
compromettere un inestimabile
testimonianza dello sviluppo della vita
in un ambiente extraterrestre e anche se
alla fine marte si rivelasse
completamente morto geologicamente morto
le stesse rocce sono un registro un
documento preziosissimo della storia
marziana e quindi ci si può chiedere
fino a che punto è lecito scavare
spaccare trivellare costruire insomma
rimodellare a misura d'uomo degli
scenari eccezionali che si sono creati e
formati e e mantenuti nel corso di
centinaia di migliori o miliardi di anni
ci sono poi molti altri discorsi su cui
sarebbe opportuno riflettere in anticipo
come affrontare i problemi collettivi le
questioni sociali della nuova civiltà
marziana che forma politica adottare
sotto quale giurisdizione sotto l'egida
di quale cultura che legami mantenere
quel pianeta d'origine o anche perché
non percorrere la strada inversa
modificando l'uomo
con i mezzi dell'ingegneria genetica e
della biomeccatronica per renderlo più
adatto al pianeta di arrivo nel
dibattito tecno scientifico questi
discorsi sono un po relegati a un ruolo
di nicchia mentre sono invece stati
sviluppati ampiamente nelle pagine di
fantascienza per esempio nel 1976
frederik pohl in uomo più aveva già
immaginato questo prototipo di uomo
marziano ottenuto tramite operazioni di
chirurgia adattiva e manipolazione
neuronale che via via poi si staccava
dal se terrestre anche emotivamente
diventando così un marziano a 360 gradi
ma forse l'opera che analizza più a
fondo tutti questi risvolti e la
trilogia di king stanley robinson che è
una lunga molto impegnativa europea
pubblicata negli anni 90 qui la
colonizzazione di marte vista con gli
occhi dei primi 100 che sono i membri
della della prima spedizione per marte
che grazie a un trattamento genetico
sviluppato proprio su marte diventano
estremamente longevi le trasformazioni
climatiche e ambientali operate
dall'uomo sull'ambiente marziano
scatenano una rivalità tra i verdi che
sono favorevoli alla terra formazione e
i rossi che invece vorrebbero mantenere
marte nel suo stato più possibile
originario
le ondate migratorie sempre più intense
specialmente in seguito al collasso
politico e ambientale di una terra
sovrappopolata andranno ad aggravare le
tensioni legate alla convivenza tra
visioni diverse e contrastanti
dell'utopia marziana tensioni che
saranno sfruttate dalle potenti società
transnazionali terrestre e da decisori e
da gruppi politici locali per mantenere
il controllo e acquisire maggiore potere
fino a quando da un lungo alternarsi di
rivoluzioni e negoziazioni si creerà
questa società marziana del tutto nuova
simile a nulla che sia mai visto prima
insomma quando arriveremo su marte se ci
arriveremo troveremo ad aspettarci già
tutte queste narrazioni che lo avranno
già popolato
non sappiamo dire se seguiremo le vie
tracciate dalla fantascienza
però possiamo dire che l'uomo su marte
segnerà uno spartiacque tra il
raggiungimento di un obiettivo e
l'apertura di nuove frontiere e per
diventare marziano l'uomo dovrà entrare
in una nuova dimensione spirituale
superare gli attuali equilibri e
trasformarsi in qualcosa che nessuno al
momento è in grado di immaginare
vale dunque sempre la regola che solo
cambiando noi stessi potremmo dar vita a
un nuovo mondo e questo come vale su
questo pianeta varrà anche per il
prossimo grazie
[Applauso]